montrez votre poitrine ça ne vous gêne
pas il faut absolument pas parce que
c'est un jeune les autres à votre avis
je pense pas Jean-Pierre belle gosse
aussi votre femme se promenait en
monokiné qu'est-ce que vous diriez
un dessin de se promener dans Saint
Tropez en maillot de bain en ville mais
sur les plages on peut être même tout nu
c'est pas gênant du tout chacun son
opinion mais alors moi pour le mien je
trouve ça un peu pas tellement bien
est-ce que vous le feriez
comme ce matin quand on est arrivé on a
vu une personne vraiment toute nue qui
faisait sa gymnastique
elles sont belles ça me déplaît pas
autrement ils peuvent les laisser de
côté